[Musique]
bonsoir bienvenue dans le débat
politique du week end ce soir donc ça
nous avec florian philippot président
des patriotes et georges kuzmanovic
fondateur de république souveraine
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france on va parler des
deux nominations ministérielles qui
suscite pas mal de polémiques
eric dupond moretti et gérald darmanin
un duo de choc qui choque à des
manifestations contre l'ancien ministre
de l'action des comptes publics nommé à
l'intérieur alors qu'il est toujours
visé par une plainte pour viol déposée
il ya trois ans les féministes ont
appelé à la démission regarder
[Applaudissements]
les trois décisions de justice en trois
ans qui me sont favorables alors il me
semble qu'au bout de trois décisions de
justice on peut penser que j'ai le droit
à la présomption d'innocence est sous le
feu des critiques également l'ancien
ténor du barreau eric dupont-moretti il
a été convoqué par le sénat pour des
éclaircissements sur ses positions
antérieures qui pourrait être
incompatible avec sa fonction
il a également été interpellé pour cette
toute première apparition à l'assemblée
nationale écoutez le
vous avez la parole un peu de silence
s'il vous plaît non vous avez raison on
n'est pas au spectacle et je vais
répondre à la question que me posent
monsieur le le député voilà des débuts
un peu compliqué pour ces deux ministres
florian philippot est ce que c'est
justifié selon ben c'est à dire que sur
monsieur darmanin le problème c'est
qu'on n'est même pas sur eux deux alors
on n'est pas sur une condamnation on
n'est même pas sûr les mises en examen
de sur une plainte
on est sur une plainte donc si vous
laissez c'est compliqué de dire
maintenant s'il ya une plainte même
quelle que soit la gravité du sujet
c'est un sujet très grave s'il s'agit de
viol que vous pouvez pas rester ministre
parce qu'on voit bien toutes les
instrumentalisations politiques assez
facile dans ce cas alors son dossier la
justice se prononcera à si évidemment
dans le cours de l'instruction
judiciaire il devait être mise en examen
il pourrait évidemment pas rester
ministre de l'intérieur mais s'ils
voulaient là pour l'instant c'est une
plainte alors sur une personne en plus
ont regardé le profil du jeudi je sais
pas si c'est si darmanin est coupable ou
innocent là-dedans j'en sais rien mais
on peut quand même éclairer un peu le
dossier par la personnalité de la
personne qui a porté plainte elle a été
condamnée elle même en 2003 et en 2005
en justice pour chantage pour menace de
crime pour avoir persécuté intimider et
soutirer des sommes d'argent à son
ancien compagnon
donc ça c'est quand même intéressant de
le savoir voilà donc moi ce qui
m'intéresserait beaucoup plus c'est de
savoir quelle est la politique du
ministre de l'intérieur
quand on voit les drames de bayonne
quand on voit ce qui s'est passé à dijon
il ya quelques semaines quand on voit
l'état devenu le ministre qui s'est
rendu sur place
oui mais ils y vont tous toujours sur
place mais moi je veux savoir ce qu'il
va faire ce qu'il va faire concrètement
sept gendarmes qui a été tué
la sas et sur la lys à intéresse
infiniment plus les français le reste on
peut pas aujourd'hui si vous voulez au
bout alors on y est complètement l'état
de droit et on n'est plus dans un état
de droit
moi j'ai vu la manifestation de ces
féministes quand elle crie violeur moi
ça me choque parce que si vous voulez il
n'est pas du tout condamné en l'état
actuel des choses pour viol donc là
c'est vraiment assez grave de dire ça
parce qu'à une plainte alors
sur l'innocence que font valoir ces
féministes florian philippot ce sont
justement et c'est justement le message
politique finalement qui a été envoyé
par emmanuel macron puisqu'on a vu des
ministres démissionner pour bien moins
que ça
georges kuzmanovic le message envoyé est
évidemment qu'il ya la présomption
d'innocence mais en choisissant
quelqu'un qui pourrait avoir des
déboires avec la justice
est ce que ça vous paraît raisonnable
écoutez il ya effectivement la
présomption d'innocence
c'est dommage c'est dommage que sur
l'angle que vous avez choisi pour ce
débat il n'y a pas une femme qui
qu'interviennent s'arrêter je pense
intéressant mais disons que en dehors de
la présomption d'innocence
monsieur darmanin et a quand même un
drôle d'oiseau
c'est celui il fait partie dé ceux qui
sont les plus dures de chez les
républicains il a été très proche de
christian vanneste un des théoriciens de
rapprochement entre une entre l air et
le front national
il a participé monsieur darmanin à une
revue maurrassienne les délégations une
sinon d'homophobie au moins deux
rapports tout à fait très réactionnaire
sur la question de l'homosexualité
il vient d'un milieu très catholiques
traditionalistes donc c'est pas certain
que ce soit le meilleur choix pour
tacler un des problèmes de sécurité qui
concerne au moins les françaises puisque
je pense que monsieur laurent philippot
sera d'accord là dessus on a bien sûr
ces agressions inacceptables de gens qui
essaient de faire tout simplement leur
travail comme ce chauffeur de bus face à
une petite criminalité qui n'est pas
suffisamment puni mais nous avons
également malheureusement dans ce pays
un nombre ahurissant de viols de femmes
officiellement c'est ses 15000 viol dans
la réalité ces quelques 200 par jour
on est donc entre 70 me les 75000 viols
par an dans la cinquième puissance
mondiale
avec un taux de deux criminels punis qui
est de l'ordre de 1%
je ne suis pas convaincu que quelqu'un
qui soit aussi traditionalistes qui
porte aussi peu d'intérêt sur ces
questions soient le plus indiqué pour
pour adresser ce problème
et dans ce sens là je suivrai les
associations féministes alors justement
c'est ce que dénonce aussi effectivement
les associations féministes caroline de
haas on va l'écouter la militante
féministe dit finalement à quoi bon
lutter contre les violences en tous cas
faites aux femmes
c'était la question était ardemment
défendu par marlène schiappa or ce ne
sera plus le cas écoutez la il n'en a
rien à cirer notre président la
république de cette thématique là il se
rend pas manifestement pas compte que
chaque jour en france plus de 250 femmes
sont victimes de viol etc en nommant
gérald darmanin à l'intérieur et dupond
moretti à la justice en fait ils
envoient un message complètement à
contre-courant de tout ce qui se passe
en france et dans le monde contre les
violences est ce que c'est un message à
contre-courant je vais d'abord vous
faire écouter eric dupond moretti à
l'époque puisqu'il est question aussi du
nouveau garde des sceaux voyez ce qu'il
disait à l'époque concernant ses
mouvements pourtant vous vous êtes
totalement illégitime à le raconter ce
que vous nous racontez pas ce que vous
voulez diriger nos vies vous emparer de
ce lacrymal de cette pâte humaine pour
en faire je ne sais quoi ma latinité m'a
permis quelques incartades quand j'étais
plus jeune dont j'ai sifflé quelques
filles qui traversait voilà on est dans
la guerre des sexes a maintenant avec
une véritable hystérisation c'est les
hommes contre les femmes
il s'avère que pour l'avenir de
l'humanité on peut pas être les uns
contre les autres ou les unes contre les
1 est-ce que c'est nabeul florian
philippot d'avoir ces propos évidemment
qu'ils sont du passé et être en même
temps le garde des sceaux et avoir à
traiter des affaires de viol ou de
harcèlement ou de maltraitance féminine
non mais écoutez je pense qu'il faut
être deux secondes sérieux nous avons
effectivement beaucoup d' affaires de
viol d'agression sexuelle il faut
regarder quand même pour quelles raisons
nous avons beaucoup de viol et on le
sait parce que nous avons beaucoup de
migrants qui arrivent en france dans des
conditions
ailleurs qu'il a devrait intéresser les
féministes c'est sur ce genre de sujet
que les féministes devraient se
mobiliser le plus souvent or c'est
justement là dessus qu'on ne les entend
pas par politiquement correct parce
qu'elle nomme pas elle n'ose pas nommer
les choses parce qu'elle n'ose pas aller
au fond des problèmes
vous avez des gens qui débarquent de
civilisation ou le statut de la femme
n'a strictement rien à voir avec ce
qu'il est en france qui est l'égal de
l'homme bien évidemment est depuis
longtemps enfin ça s'est construit
malheureusement plus lentement que ça
mais quand même ça fait partie d'eads
acquis aujourd'hui en france il arrive
brutalement en france ils sont amenés
par des passeurs par des mafias et
israël dans un pays ils viennent de
civilisation c'est absolument pas le cas
donc nous avons et toute l'europe est
concernée
des viols qui sont largement liée à ce
phénomène migratoire anarchique ce qui
veut pas dire je précise tout de suite
que tout immigré forcément un violeur en
puissance je le dis à ceux qui font
semblant de ne pas comprendre les choses
et qu'ils veulent voir des amalgames là
où il y en a pas
je le dis clairement ce n'est pas le cas
ça n'est pas mon propos est mon propos
il est extrêmement précis et extrêmement
clair mais c'est là dessus qu'on doit
entendre les féministes alors moi ce
qu'a dit ce qu'a pensé dupond moretti à
un moment là géré jusque déjà entendu
voilà on peut dire c'est assez bof ou
ccc sable c'est sa version des choses ça
mais il n'a rien dit de particulièrement
scandaleux il a le droit encore d'avoir
une opinion sur mythe ou je ne sais quoi
et ça ne doit pas lui disqualifiée pour
être ministre moi je pense que ma kron a
nommé a fait nommer dupond moretti un
ministre pour que justement on ne parle
que de ça pour qu'on parle de ce
personnage dont on sait qu'il est
controversée dans son c qui va faire
couler beaucoup d'encre et ça fonctionne
ça fait une semaine qu'il nous a lancé
une baballe et qu'on court après et
qu'on parle de dupond moretti moi ce qui
m'intéresse encore une fois en matière
de justice et l'exécution des peines ce
qui m'intéresse c'est l'indépendance de
la justice
ce qui m'intéresse c'est est ce qu'il ya
instrumentalisation politique de la
justice comme on l'a vu avec ceux des
récents scandales
ça ce sont des vraies questions qui
intéressent les français et le peuple
français
plutôt que de débattre sur ce qu'a dit
il ya trois ans sur un plateau de télé
concernant mitu dupond-moretti je pense
que ce sera très intéressant
alors justement il va devoir donner la
réforme de la juste
eric dupond moretti et notamment cette
question de l'indépendance du parquet
notamment georges kuzmanovic est-ce que
c'est l'homme de la situation et je veux
répondre mais juste monsieur philippe
hollevout fait une confusion si
effectivement on peut se retrouver
parce que notre système d'assimilation
républicaine des rats ils ne
fonctionnent pas bien parce que la
république ne fonctionne pas assez et
qu'on peut se retrouver avec des
populations
une partie des populations immigrées qui
ne s'assimile pas et ne prennent pas en
compte les valeurs de la république et
qui donc véhicules leurs valeurs
traditionalistes le viol lui
malheureusement frappe très largement
tout le monde toute la france dans tous
les milieux sociaux et la plupart des
viols ne sont pas comme vous savez ne
sont pas des viols mais si j'allais dire
la sauvette sont des viols dans le
réseau familial amical
est-ce qui est ce qui rend encore plus
difficile leur qualification en tant que
violent pardon ça ne savait pas
contradictoire je suis d'accord avec son
arme et je vais rêver insiste sales
bestioles et donc la question réellement
en termes de criminalité ce que nous
sommes pour qu'il y ait que la clé tout
et criminalité soit soit soit soient
prises en compte
celle ci il est quand même très très peu
je pense que là dessus tant du point de
vue de la police que la justice on
pourrait avoir un peu plus de puissance
de frappe maintenant sur la réforme de
la justice
moi j'y crois j'y crois assez peu parce
que pain parce que monsieur dit pour
moretti effectivement dupond moretti est
surtout là je pense pour attirer les
feux de la scène ce qui le fait très
bien d'ailleurs depuis la nomination de
ce nouveau gouvernement mais se plie
pour raison maintenant
pour la suite je vois très mal et le
maquereau qui se perçoit comme le seul
apte à dire ce qui doit être fait qui
est qui et course qui se considère comme
jupiter a laissé partir un élément
central du contrôle politique mais de
notre point de vue en tout cas
république souveraine nous convient vous
parlez de l'indépendance du parquet par
rapport à l'exécutif exactement où
l'indépendance du parquet par rapport à
l'exécutif
en tout cas il ya au moins deux parquets
qui devrait devenir indépendant et donc
il faudra augmenter les moyens et les
doubler c'est le parquet antiterroriste
et c'est le parquet national financiers
l'un contre les terroristes l'autre
contre les grands fraudeurs fiscaux la
grande corruption la grande qui vénèrent
criminalité financière
compte tenu des soutiens à la
présidentielle à monsieur mâcon compte
tenu de ses amis
compte tenu de son origine
professionnelle dans la banque compte
tenu des services immense financier
qu'il a rendus à bank of america
car à la banque rothschild à bouygues en
bradant à nos fleurons industriels
alstom alors plus grands bénéfices je le
vois très très mal un rendre indépendant
un parc national financiers dont ils
seraient une des premières cibles
légitimes donc je n'y crois pas un seul
instant tout c'est de la poudre aux yeux
il n'y aura bien évidemment aucun aucune
indépendance de au moins en tout cas de
ses parquets centraux pour une meilleure
démocratie en france
voilà je n'y crois pas florian philippot
est ce que vous y croyez c'est vrai que
eric dupond moretti et n'ai pas aimé des
magistrats il y en a même un qui a
démissionné aujourd'hui en guise de
contestation lui était partisan de ce
lien de l'exécutif avec le parquet alors
que emmanuel macron a promis de les
séparer qu'est ce que vous en pensez est
ce que cette réforme sera possible si
vous voulez qu'il y ait une politique
générale judiciaire en france c'est
important
c'est à dire qu'il faut quand même des
instructions générales évidemment
général et pas individuelle parce que on
doit avoir à peu près la même justice
sur tous les points du territoire
national où ça ici on ne peut pas faire
sans après ce que ce qui est apparu
très clairement c'est la politisation et
l'instrumentalisation politique de la
justice et c'est vrai effectivement
depuis la création du pnr en 2013 sous
françois hollande on a vu des récentes
des livres des enquêtes qui sont soit
ouverte
je crois pour fillon ça a été ouvert
dans les 24 heures en 2017 par le plf et
ça a été il a été mis en examen en cinq
semaines fin c'était un truc qui ne dit
pas qu'il est innocent sur le fond mais
salue scheer sur le rythme judiciaire
c'était du jamais vu bon au même moment
il y avait la soirée à las vegas qui
sortait dans la presse avec le maquereau
qui avaient participé dans d'autres
sanctions
hélas le pnf n'avait pas ouvert une
enquête donc si vous voulez on voit bien
et même chose sur la xxi colère on s'est
sorti dans la presse que ce avant là il
n'y a pas eu
enfin on a vu qu'il ya eu quand même à
un traitement de faveur en quelque sorte
puisqu'il ya eu intervention par une
lettre en 2019 du président de la
république et ensuite un deuxième
rapport de police qui contredisaient le
premier qui blanchissait alexis colère
tout ça est extrêmement malsain montre
que effectivement il ya
instrumentalisation politique de la
justice mais je dirais même aussi contre
des gens lambda moi je me souviens que
400 gilet jaune ont été mis en prison
avec mandat de dépôt c'est à dire que
ils ont été condamnés à la prison ferme
et immédiatement mis sous cellule 401
emile ont été condamnés à la prison
ferme au total ce qui complètement
incroyable là on a fait preuve de l'
inverse du laxisme convoi contre
certains voyous dans certains quartiers
qui eux bénéficient du laxisme quotidien
de la justice donc c'est ça moi qui me
choque et là je pense effectivement
qu'il n'y aura pas de mal heureusement
de réformes qu'il n'y aura pas
d'évolution que macron gardera à la main
cette instrumentalisation de la justice
et que dupont moretti est juste là pour
faire causer les gazettes mais qu'il
n'est pas là pour faire de véritables
réformes
et ça marche bien et ça marche bien la
preuve on ne parle que de ça depuis une
semaine et on ne parle pas du fond des
dossiers on va on va en venir à un
gérald darmanin jean castex lui a
apporté un soutien de ferme hier lors de
son déplacement à dijon on l'écouté
j'aurai votre brève réaction
à suivre je suis aujourd'hui
accompagné de gerald tarn amiens
ministre de l'intérieur nommé sur ma
proposition par le président mal et
qu'il bénéficie de toute notre confiance
pour exercer cette haute fonction
réaction vous avez une minute georges
kuzmanovic la moralisation de la vie
publique on en est loin
oui je crois qu on en est loin mais ce
qui m'a fait rire moi c'est s'est nommé
sur ma proposition même si monsieur
castex avait choisi monsieur darmanin
alors qu'on sait très bien que celui ci
faisait pression depuis des semaines sur
l'elysée pour être nommé à ce poste non
ça a beaucoup plus à voir avec des
luttes de pouvoir internes et le désir
de monsieur macron de conserver la
mainmise sur le les républicains et
monsieur darmana lui permet d'avoir un
bon contrôle sur le nord de la france et
sur les plus rudes les plus durs ne les
plus réactionnaires chez les
républicains puisque je vous faisais son
pedigree tout à l'heure et florian
philippot gérald darmanin et jean castex
d'ailleurs 20 qui ont apporté un soutien
ferme aux policiers un par rapport à ce
qui s'est passé auparavant le pont est
quand même différent c'est une bonne
chose
non mais là je suis assez d'accord c'est
une nomination très politicienne on voit
bien qu'il ya beaucoup de sarkozyste a
d'ailleurs dans ce nouveau gouvernement
mais mme bachelot
monsieur darmanin par jean castex
lui-même qui a été qui a été très très
proche de nicolas sarkozy qui est proche
toujours nicolas sarkozy donc on voit
qu'on est beaucoup plus dans une optique
politicienne dans ces nominations
qu'autre chose
moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est qu'est ce
que va faire darmanin pour rétablir si
vous les problèmes pour les français la
tranquillité la paix publique
mais ben je me dis que dans un pays que
tu fasses on appartient à schengen à
l'union européenne c'est impossible
voilà parce qu'on maîtrise même pas nos
frontières nationales parce qu'on est
soumis à une austérité qui s'applique
aussi au ministère de l'intérieur aux
policiers aux gendarmes ou douaniers etc
donc moi ces questions structurantes qui
m'intéresse et je pense que le casting
dans ce modèle là tant qu'on n'est pas
sortis de ce système union européenne
schengen ça n'a pas beaucoup
d'importance et on est dans la petite
politique politicienne dans la petite
tambouille voilà après qui leur assurait
policier va après
le passage piteux de monsieur castaner
qui lui voulait se mettre à genoux
devant le gang traoré on peut le
comprendre mais est ce que ça change
fondamentalement les conditions de
travail des policiers est là au rapport
entre les français et leur police
aujourd'hui je pense que non
malheureusement on verra le temps nous
dira merci beaucoup en tout cas merci à
tous les deux d'avoir participé à ce
débat c'est le dernier débat politique
du samedi avant avant la rentrée merci
je vous souhaite à tous de bonnes
vacances rester avec nous sur rt france
[Musique]